we begin this half hour with the
country's latest economic snapshot on
friday the labor department released a
stronger than expected jobs report for
june the economy added 372 thousand jobs
last month and the unemployment rate
remained unchanged at 3.6 percent just
above a 50-year low all this despite
record inflation high gasoline prices
and a volatile stock market here to help
us make sense of it all is our news our
cbs news business analyst jill singer
good morning jill so the big question
what are the main takeaways from this
report
you know i think that the labor market
is really entering a transition phase
because are just at the beginning of
seeing job creation taper off now what
do i mean you said stronger than
expected report absolutely but look at
the first three months of this year we
average more than half a million jobs a
month then you look at the second
quarter and then it's more like 380 000
jobs a month and i think that that's
what we're going to see for the rest of
the year now listen there's no doubt
about it the first six months have been
really strong more than 2.7 million jobs
created in six months that's about 20
more than a whole year of average gains
during the 2010 so we still are in a
strong labor market
well on that note then jill with
inflation we're seeing at 41 year highs
of 8.6 are americans earning enough to
balance it all out to absorb these
higher prices
this is so difficult because what we saw
in this report is wages up by 5.1
from a year ago normal times pre-covet
this would be spectacular but as you
note 41-year highs in inflation at 8.6
percent a lot of americans are falling
behind and you know how they're funding
that gap they're spending down the
savings that they accumulated during the
pandemic economists tell me it looks
like americans have spent about
600 billion dollars of the savings they
built up we built up about two and a
half trillion dollars of savings that's
how a lot of americans are making do
with these higher prices
it's okay on the short term but long
term is where you start to worry what
about interest rates we've talked about
that each time where we do speak with
you how is this latest report going to
impact the decision on interest rates
well the fed's going to meet in about
three weeks and i fully expect that the
central bank will raise interest rates
by another three quarters of one percent
at that meeting you know listen the
central bank is pretty clear these high
prices have got to come down and by the
way the fed has told us they are willing
to see employment take a hit in order to
bring down prices so get ready for
higher rates bad news for borrowers but
actually good news for savers
all right jill thank you for the
perspective we appreciate it